(click)
(beeping)
- Who's an assistant professor
of ophthalmology at UCSF.
Got her ophthalmology training
here at Boston Children's
and Massachusets Eye Hospital,
and I first heard you
speak at the advances
and pediatrics course and want to
thank Dr. Andrea Cello for bringing you
there so we could bring you here.
- It's my pleasure, thank you.
(applause)
Alright, I'm gonna set up a backup timer
on my phone also, just
in case I lose sight
of the green button here, but it's
absolutely my pleasure to
be here this afternoon,
thank you so much for having me to
speak to you about vision impairments,
and the appropriate way
to do vision screening
in patients with
developmental disabilities,
especially the pediatric patients
with developmental disabilities.
As I am a pediatric ophthalmologist,
I will be focusing my talk mostly on that.
So just to begin, I have no disclosures
to report just yet, as an overview today,
I'm going to be speaking to you first
about the importance of vision screening
in general and the impact that it has.
Secondly, talking to you about the vision
problems that we often see in children,
especially those that have
developed mental disabilities.
Then I'll speak to you about some
conventional screening tasks that we have
readily available at our disposal just
in our normal clinic that
I'll show you how to do,
and hopefully you can implement
in your own practices.
And then lastly, I'll talk to you about
some of the new technologies that we
have for automated vision screening
so that you might be able to use
these modalities as well.
So to go through our learning objectives,
number one, to understand
the impact of vision
screening in children with
developmental disabilities.
Number two, to learn two conventional
methods of vision screening.
Three, to learn the four different
types of automated screenings,
and finally, you know, every test
is not without it's
pitfalls or it's negative
implications or it's cons,
and so I sort of wanna go through the pros
and cons in each of these different
modalities that you can make your
best informed decision about what
would work for you in your practice.
Okay, so to begin, why do we even
need to perform vision screening?
About one in four
American school children,
which is a very, very high statistic,
actually have some form of vision
disability or vision problem.
And then this percentage is much higher,
as you can imagine, in children
with developmental disabilities.
This is often due to the fact that
the underlying etiology that explains
their developmental delay or disability
can also affect the visual system,
so factors such as prenatal
or perinatal insults
or acquired injuries can also affect
the neurosensory pathway
that affects vision.
Patients that are developmentally delayed
and also are very, very
young pediatric patients
often don't realize that they
have a visual impairment,
or if they do, they don't have a way
to convey that message to their
parents or to their doctors.
And so it's important that
we, as the practitioners,
are the ones that actually
are being proactive
and screening these patients.
And then finally, these patients,
when they have many other
medical comorbidities,
or a lot of other things going on,
parents often are often overlooking
the vision impairments or the potential
vision disabilities that they also have
just because there's so many other things
that they're sort of dealing with,
and many other doctor's appointments.
So it's really our prerogative as the
pediatric ophthalmologists and as
primary care doctors to be the first line
of defense for these patients when
it comes to vision screening,
and then appropriately refer it to us
as the more subspecialized
care when it's needed.
So visiual disabilities,
as you might guess,
has a lot of impact on people's lives.
Firstly, it can impact
someone's ability to learn,
also their career
opportunities down the line.
There's a couple of studies that sort of
try to quantify the actual monetary
or economic burden of
unilateral vision loss,
and I would probably argue that the values
that are sort of mentioned
in this one paper
are under-balling it a little bit.
So this one paper had described
unilateral vision loss by the age of ten
can result in upwards of
$67,000 of cost over a lifetime,
and about a 10% decrease
in quality of life.
That's, I think, is the underestimate of
what we can sort of imagine.
Because, especially in patients that have
other forms of developmental
of neurologic disability,
it can impact other aspects of their life.
Vision is so important in the development
of motor advancement, social interaction,
self care, so if there isn't
appropriate vision established,
these patients sort of fall short in these
other aspects of their development.
So the most common vision problems
that we see in all children at large,
and I'll sort of go
through the specific issues
that we see in patients
with developmental delay,
are number one, amblyopia.
So this is the one major thing that
a lot of our vision screening
testing is looking for.
I'll describe what amblyopia actually is
in the subsequent slides, but basically,
it is a failure of the development
of the neurosensory pathway that allows
one to see, and it's due to problems
that occur during early
development that impair vision.
So these risk factors
that can impair vision
include a refractive
error, so needing glasses,
so having a constant blur
in vision can therefore
decrease the visual input
that the brain is receiving
and therefore the development of
that eye doesn't occur normally.
Secondly, strabismus, or
misalignment of the eyes.
When the eyes are not
actually working together,
there is what we call
competitive inhibition.
So one eye takes over as the dominant eye,
leaving the other eye to
become lazy or amblyopic.
And then finally, something that blocks
visual input from entering into the eye,
and then therefore, being
translated into the brain,
such as a cataract or some
sort of a pacification
in the front of the eye
can result in amblyopia.
Aside from amblyopia, though,
there are several other factors
that can result in visual impairments.
This is number one, just
needing glasses in general.
Run of the mill refractive error.
Number two, strabismus, or
misalignment of the eyes,
doesn't necessarily need to cause
a decrease in vision
in one eye or another,
but it can cause a
decrease in visual ability,
because it can limit depth perception.
And then finally, any other structural
abnormalities of the eye.
So just to go through
amblyopia a little bit more,
it's defined in the reduction of
best-corrected visual
acuity, so this means
with appropriate glasses that cannot
be attributed to any structural
abnormality of the eyes.
This neurosensory abnormality.
It's because the brain is not receiving
the normal amount of
stimuli that it should
as the visual stem is developing.
It's actually quite common amongst
the general population of children,
it's about two to 3% of the population,
it is the most common
referral to my practice
as a pediatric ophthalmologist,
and most pediatric ophthalmology
practices at large,
but this percentage I
would argue is much higher
in patients with developmental delay,
because these patients actually have
a much higher incidence of those three
risk factors that can result in amblyopia.
Needing glasses, having strabismus,
or having some sort of structural
abnormality of the eye.
It's important that we
screen for amblyopia,
and the incidence of amblyopia can
actually increase by about
2.5, 2.6 fold by age eight
if screening is not done by age two.
So that's a substantial amount of burden
that we can be decreasing by
doing early screening of patients.
And why do we wanna screen
for amblyopia early?
It's because like I mentioned before,
it's caused by risk factors that
happen during early development.
So that's before the age of seven.
So if someone develops a need for glasses
or strabismus after that age,
amblyopia may not develop, which is good,
because then it means that there might
not be a long-term impact on vision.
However, it still might
result in a visual impairment.
So amblyopia also is reversible when
it's treated within this sensitive period,
so between birth and seven years of age.
So while 90% can be treated by age three,
this goes down to
virtually 0% if a patient
presents to us at age 10 with
a diagnosis of amblyopia.
So when we think about patients
with developmental disability,
I'm sorry for that
small font on the slide,
but I wanted to include
this particular chart,
because I thought it was a very nice
summary of the types of vision impairment
that we see in patients with various forms
of developmental disability compared to
the general pediatric population.
And so sort of going through several forms
of developmental disability such as
intellectual disability, cerebral palsy,
preterm birth, Down's Syndrome,
all of these different forms actually
have a higher rate of just
vision impairment in general.
So vision under 220, significantly higher
than the general population,
which is about 0.06%.
Refractive errors are largest,
so about over 50% of this
population actually need glasses.
Similarly, over 50% of this population
also have misalignment of their eyes.
So that's a significant difference
compared to about the six to 7%
that we see in a general
pediatric population.
So this is why vision screening
might be even more important when
we're talking about children who
have developmental disabilities.
So our current recommendations
for vision screening
are to perform vision screening on all
patients between the age of three to five
to detect the presence of
amblyopia or it's risk factors,
and this is something that
was agreed upon by many, many
large organizations such at the
U.S Presentative Task Force,
the American Academy of Ophthalmology,
and then my organization,
The American Academy of Pediatric
Ophthalmology and Strabismus.
And then in addition to that,
the American Academy of Pediatric
Ophthalmology and Strabismus actually
recommends that patients that
have a neurodevelopmental
disability actually be referred to
an eye care provider, an
optometrist or an ophthalmologist
for a comprehensive eye exam regardless
of what the vision
screening testing shows.
This is because oftentimes,
these patients may not
have a positive test on
the vision screening,
or even if they do, they might qualify
for a general ophthalmology exam to enable
them to be enrolled in
early intervention services.
But this isn't what actually happens,
unfortunately the
requirements of preventative
eye care vary very broadly
throughout the country.
Only 40 out of our 50 states require any
vision screening for any children,
and only 16 require vision screening
for preschool age of children.
This is the age that it's important to do
before amblyopia becomes
irreversible, that's a minority.
And then in 2011, only 40% of
children below the age of five
actually underwent some
form of vision screening.
While this is up from the 21% in the 80's,
we still have quite a way to go.
And then only one in five children
with some form of developmental disability
that should qualify for
early intervention programs
are actually enrolled in
these before the age of three.
So obviously, there is a good need
for a standardized protocol,
and more widespread and efficient
approach for vision screening.
So in order to sort of
answer what that might be,
you sort of have to ask what is
vision screening actually looking for?
So number one, wanna look for amblyopia,
which is sort of in the
center of this Venn diagram,
and then also the risk factors
that can contribute to amblyopia,
but also can result in vision
loss in it's own right.
So this is the need for
glasses or refractive error,
having any structural
abnormality of the eye,
or having a misalignment of the eye.
Our conventional screening
tests that we have
and are very easy to do and are readily
available and cheap because we have
this equipment already in our clinics,
are vision testing with optotype acuity,
and then something that's
called a red reflux test
with the direct ophthalmoscope,
that's the Bruckner Red Reflex Test.
And these can look for all three
of these different components
that can result in amblyopia.
So before we talk about
visual acuity measurements,
we have to know that the normal
visual acuity does vary by age.
We don't actually expect our children
to develop 20/20 vision until
they're at least five years old.
Part of this has to do with the actual
development of their visual pathway,
but also their ability
to perform the tests.
So our cutoffs for screening is usually
around the age of 20/40
by age three to four,
and 20/30 by age five, and this is with
their standard optotype
recognition testing.
And children that have disability,
they will oftentimes, that form
of testing is not possible.
Especially if they're not able
to name or if they're nonverbal.
So if a patient is able to have some
level of cognitive skill, such as the
ability to match and recognize shapes,
one test that we often do
is called Lea matching.
You show a single optotype on the screen
that has a varying size, so that
sort of tells you their acuity,
and then they have a
sheet in front of them
with the same shapes, there's four
different shapes in the test,
and they point to which
one they see on the screen.
This actually works very, very well
in some of our patients are uncooperative.
Even if they don't have a
developmental disability,
if they're just shy,
but we often found this
to be very, very helpful in our patients
that are nonverbal for severe autism,
or cerebral palsy, or any
other developmental disability.
And then if that isn't even possible,
if a patient isn't even able to have
that ability to match,
to look on the screen,
to point, we also have
resolution-based visual acuity tests.
This is called the
teller-card acuity test.
Basically with this test, we show a board
of stripes on one side and a plain
sort of screen on the other side,
and we look to see if there's
a saccade towards the shape,
towards the striped pattern.
That would sort of indicate that
there is acuity of that level.
And then, the gradient of those stripes
can actually decrease,
become finer and finer,
and then you're able to determine
whether someone is able
to resolve the difference
between a striped pattern
versus a blank side,
and that sort of gives
you a sense of acuity.
So for this test, there's
no talking that's needed,
there's no pointing that's needed,
so virtually all of our patients,
so long as they're able to
fixate or look at something,
they're able to perform this test,
and we're actually able to
get an objective acuity.
So any type of optotype visual acuity
is a good form of
testing, and sort of just
looking at the value
of doing this testing,
there's been a couple of different
validation studies that have shown that
the positive prediction value for
doing any form of optotype
visual acuity testing
is 60% when it comes to experienced users,
those who know how to
do a visual acuity test.
But when it comes to lay screeners,
you know, if it was to
be done in a drug store,
or sometimes in day cares, the positive
predictive value falls
substantially to about 27%,
so that's sort of something to keep in our
back pocket when we think about
the utility of this form of testing.
So the second form of conventional testing
is called the Bruckner Red Reflex Test.
This is a test where a
direct ophthalmoscope is used
to shine a light into
both of the patient's eyes
from a distance of about
two to three feet away.
So you don't have to actually
approach the patient very close,
which is very, very helpful in a lot
of our patients that have sensory issues,
or just feel uncomfortable
with bright lights by them,
or won't let you occlude
one eye or another,
'cause this is a binocular test.
And basically, by shining
this light in both eyes,
you are able to tell two things.
Number one, is there a visual
access of pacification,
so is there a structural
abnormality of the eye?
You can tell that by seeing if
there's an abnormal red reflex.
And then secondly, you
can actually compare
the quality of the red
reflex between the two eyes,
and determine if one
eye is the fixating eye
versus the amblyopic eye.
So here in this picture, this patient
is looking straight at you with
the direct ophthalmoscope, and you can see
here that one of the eyes
has a brighter crescent
than the other eye, which is dimmer.
It's actually that dimmer eye that's
the one that's fixating on you,
and it's the brighter eye that
has some sort of abnormality.
You don't necessarily
need to know what that is,
but you know at this point that you
can refer to an ophthalmologist
or an optometrist
to have a comprehensive eye exam,
because almost assuredly, this patient
has either a refractive error or
a strabismus, or some form of amblyopia.
With an experienced user,
which most practitioners
would be very quite easily,
this has a very high
predictive value of about 89%.
So I think this is an underutilized test,
but these conventional approaches
do have substantial barriers.
As we saw from the visual acuity testing,
the positive predictive
value is quite dependent
on the experience of the person
who's taking the measurements.
Part of this is because
these tests do work
in better and more cooperative children,
oftentimes when they're older.
We do tend to have difficulty, even
with the Bruckner Red
Reflux sometimes on children
who are developmentally delayed,
or who are younger or just
not cooperative in general.
The visual acuity test does need
to be done monocularly, to
test one eye, then the other,
which is very time consuming.
And so for that reason, people find this
to be inefficient, and perhaps more
cost-inefficient for the physicians.
So because of that,
there's been a big push
for automated vision screeners.
And there's two different
types I wanna talk about.
Number one is the photorefractors,
which many of you might have already seen,
and then a new technology that I sort
of want to touch upon just a bit.
So our photorefractors, there's three
different types that I'll go through.
But these are designed to
be operated by lay users.
So, librarians, someone
who's in a daycare,
anyone can use this
test because it's quick,
it can be done at a distance,
it doesn't have as much user variability,
and it has sort of checks in place
that you get an accurate result.
It's a binocular test, you don't need
to cover one eye or another, it takes
about five seconds to do, and it can
detect amblyopia risk factor, so normally
a refractive error so it can sort
of do a gross measurement of what
a glasses prescription would be,
and then also if there's a strabismus,
or a misalignment of the eye.
So before I did my talk last
year at Advances in Pediatrics,
I actually had all of
these vision screeners
sent to my office so I can try them out
and sort of get my own feeling,
'cause I'm gonna be validating them
anyway in my clinic, the
comprehensive eye exam,
just to see how accurate they were,
what our experience was and what we
felt our patients felt about it.
So the first one we tested was a
Spot Vision Screener by Welch Allyn,
it's an infrared screener,
it's used at a distance
away from the patient and can
measure a refractive error
and strabismus, and then it gives you
an instant interpretation
with pass or fail
for whether to refer to an optometrist
or an ophthalmologist or not,
and then this is based
off of standard guidelines
that were set forth by
the American Academy
of Pediatric Ophthalmology and Strabismus,
and this is our technician sort of
holding this device testing it on me,
and it sort of played
these flashing lights.
It sort of moved in an undulating slow way
with these bird chirping
sounds, it was quite soothing.
Our patients actually said that they
liked it very much and they
were sort of enthralled by
it, so we thought it had
a positive experience in that regard.
And then the second one that we looked at
was the plusoptiX
screener, it's very similar
to the Spot Vision Screener as well,
an infrared screener that
can be used at a distance,
can measure refractive
error and strabismus.
The one advantage to this one is that
you can modify your referral criteria.
Here in the U.S., we most always
will be using the same criteria,
but this would be allow it to be
more applicable in different countries
because there are different guidelines
for one to refer to an
ophthalmologist or not.
Likewise, it gives you
a pass or fail result.
The one difference that we sort of
felt and experienced was here there
was sort of this clown shape with
a strobe light and a louder, almost
like a laughing, cackling noise,
which while it drew attention,
a lot of our patients
were quite scared of it,
and I was a little scared of it as well.
But specifically, for this population,
for our autistic population
or those with sensory issues,
it was quite a difficult
test for them to tolerate,
at least in our experience.
And then finally, the third test that we
looked at was the GoCheck Kids.
This is a cellphone-based vision screener.
It works a little bit differently
than the other two vision screeners
in that it takes a photograph of
the reflex that's admitted out of
the two patients' eyes with a fixation,
and then based off of that photograph,
they're able to give an estimate
of refractive error from the crescent
of the light that's seen
from that photograph.
It's not able to tell
strabismus like the other ones,
but it's able to at least
give you a measurement
of refractive error, and then similarly,
give you a pass or fail and when to
refer to a pediatric ophthalmologist.
Because it's on your phone, it's a lot
easier to use, you just sort of
subscribe to a monthly subscription.
I think our UCSF pediatricians
are actually using this device.
The one thing though, is that
it requires perfect fixation,
it doesn't really give you that
same sort of feedback that the other two
do in terms of ensuring that
you have that perfect fixation,
'cause otherwise you'll have a very, very
high false positive rate.
And then the one advantage that we felt
was that because it's cell phones,
and unfortunately in this day
and age with millennial parents,
everyone's taking photos and selfies,
our kids are very used to having
photos taken of them with a phone,
so they're ready to cheese and
be ready to look at this photo screen
or to have the test be done.
So I do wanna go through,
like I mentioned,
some of the pros and cons of these tests.
I sort of mentioned the advantages
of automated vision screening in general
that it allows anyone to be
able to use very, very quickly,
and be done in a relatively accurate way.
There are sort of downsides to these
vision screening devices as well,
and a lot of them has to
do with their positive
and negative predictive values.
So I wanna go through, first of all,
just as a review,
positive predictive value
is the percent of the time that a positive
value is actually a true positive value
that we see as ophthalmologists
when we were doing our
confirmatory eye exam.
So that's important to us, we want
a high positive predictive value,
because we don't want to
have too many referrals
that then end up being negative.
However, as a screener, the
negative predictive value
is more important to you, because you
want to ensure that a negative test
is truly negative, and it's not truly
missing an actual positive test.
So as a screener, the
negative predictive value,
having a high value for
that is important to you.
So ideally, you would have
a high value for both,
oftentimes we can't get that.
So, one of the things that I looked for
specifically when I was looking for
validation testing was the use of these
devices in the general population.
Not in an ophthalmologist's office,
which is where a lot of these validation
tests were actually done.
Because, as ophthalmologists
and as ophthalmic technicians,
our staff are very, very trained
with all of these different devices.
So we're gonna always get a higher value
for the positive predictive value
and the negative predictive value.
But that's not reflective of what
the general use of what
this device would be.
So I specifically sought
out community-based
usages of these devices.
So the first one I looked at
was the Spot Vision Screener.
This was a study that
was done in the community
in over 7,000 children of various ages,
and the screener was
used by lay personnel.
The positive predictive value for
any amblyogenic risk factor was 65%.
It's okay, they didn't check the negative
predictive value, 'cause only the patients
that had the positive predictive value
were then referred to a
pediatric ophthalmologist
to have a confirmatory eye exam, so we
don't know if the negative values
were truly negative or not.
And then, specifically for
patients with developmental delay,
I found this study that again, was used
by lay screeners in patients that had
all forms of intellectual or neurologic
or developmental disabilities.
They had 100 children that were
included in the study,
again, various age ranges.
And here they mentioned both the positive
and the negative predictive values
because all of these
patients were screened
by a pediatric
ophthalmologist or optometrist
as they should have been since
they do have these disabilities.
They found though, that
the spot vision screener
had a slightly lower
positive predictive value
in this population of about 58%,
with a negative predictive value
is very, very high, of about 86%.
So I think you can feel assured that
a negative test, even in a developmentally
delayed population is
actually truly negative.
And then, sort of
similarly, when I'm looking
at the plusoptiX screener, this is a study
in all children, but this study included
over 1,000 children of various ages
using the Spot Vision
Screener by lay operators.
The positive predictive value of
this screening test was much higher
than the Welch Allyn test at 81%,
but again, this study didn't calculate
the negative predictive value for
the same reason as the previous study.
And then I found this one for the
use of the plusoptiX screener in
patients with intellectual disability,
which includes at least
a subset of patients
that have some sort of developmental
disability, and they
found here that again,
when used by non medical personnel,
this screening test had a lower
positive predictive
value in this population,
though the negative predictive
value is quite high.
So I think we can feel assured that
with either one of these
automated vision screeners,
a negative predictive
value is truly negative,
but even still for other social
reasons or coordination reasons,
will most likely will actually still
need it at an actual eye exam.
And then looking at the
GoCheck Kids device,
this is unfortunately a newer technology,
so they don't have a lot
of validation studies.
So they have one in the community,
and they don't have one in the
developmentally disabled population,
however, in this particular study,
looking at the GoCheck
Kids Screening device,
this was used in eye centers,
this was used by eye personnel.
The positive predictive value was
actually quite low, at 57%,
and then preliminary data from RUCSF
sort of we're looking back
at our population here,
is even lower and can
get even lower than that
if it's used in patients that
are under 12 months of age.
The negative predictive value,
however, is high, it's 83%.
So all of these different
forms of vision screeners
are looking for different
risk factors for amblyopia.
They're looking for need for
glasses, or subtle strabismus.
But they're not actually
looking for amblyopia itself.
So the question is, is there some form
of technology that can actually just
look for that directly without sort
of beating around the bush and give
us a more accurate test result.
So yes, there is this new technology
that's just been created.
It's not out in the market
yet, but it will be soon.
This is called the Blinq by Rebion.
It's a device that uses something
that's called neural performance scanning,
which basically means it uses a specific
type of laser that rather than taking
a photo of the reflex
that's generated by the eye,
it actually sends a laser to the fovea,
which is the back part of the eye,
the central part of vision.
And then based off of the birefringence
that's received back from
the laser reflection,
between the two eyes they can tell
if there's a subtle misalignment
or a subtle discrepancy, and thereby tell
if there's actually truly amblyopia,
or even a strabismus of about one degree,
which is something that even us
as eye professionals can't
do on our general eye exam.
This is, again, a very new technology,
so there's only one validation study
and again, this one is
used in an eye care center.
Here they found that when this particular
technology was used in this population
of 300 patients, it had a very, very high
sensitivity, specificity, and a very
high positive and
negative predictive value.
So this could very well
be the future of vision
screening in our patient populations.
So I sort of put this chart together
just in our last minute or so of
going through the vision screening
modalities that we've talked about,
sort of thinking about the
pros and cons of each of them.
The biggest thing that we wanna look at
is the negative predictive value high,
and is the positive predictive value high.
Unfortunately when we look at our patients
with developmental disabilities,
that positive predictive value is
a little bit lower than the
general pediatric population,
but so long as the negative
predictive value is high,
I would argue that it's a good
screening test to be
used and can be trusted.
When it comes to the cost though,
which is the big question,
that's where the difference really lies.
When you're thinking about vision testing,
or the Bruckner Red Reflex,
these are things that
you can do in your clinic with equipment
that you already most likely have,
so it's about a cost of zero.
So for the automated vision screeners,
these roughly cost about
$7,000 one time each.
The GoCheck Kids, which
is the phone screener,
costs about $60 a month, and then
this new technology, we don't know.
We'll see how much it
actually ends up costing,
hopefully not too much.
So just in conclusion, early vision
screening is needed for
all pediatric patients,
especially those with
developmental disabilities.
Conventional methods such as visual
acuity testing and Bruckner Reflex
are very, very viable
options in this population,
and should still be trusted.
However, in order to make our screening
more efficient for the general population
from a public health standpoint,
automated vision testing
can improve our efficiency.
And then finally, newer technology
can provide better results potentially.
Thank you.
(applause)